and so it is selfish
if you have a good support system it
works well for you okay
that's one word
what about the sperm donor though but
there's still a father involved to have
that for that child to be created
there's still a father involved there's
a sperm which comes from a father yeah
I know but most most women right now are
single but they have a good support
system that makes the child uh even
better it works out for the child better
but if you have no support no no it
doesn't no no I said I said most I
didn't say everyone I think that's a
word because there's a lot of a lot of
women you can have a child if you want a
baby I don't think that's inherently
selfish when you put it your kid at
every statistical disadvant no no
offense to the single mothers on the
piano you can every statistical
disadvantage if you talk to people that
came from single mother home say I want
a father you're more likely to go to
prison you're more likely to end up
homeless you're more likely to go to
jail like like every you're more likely
to drop out of school run away from home
I already said I think inherently having
children is a bit selfish but that's
besides that's the precise
please why would you push you could have
a kid I'm saying I'm saying if you
genuinely want a child and you think you
have the facilities the money the
support system everything required other
than the male figure required to have a
children and you really really want a
child it's selfish but you can do do you
do you know I think a father figure is
required I think you can live you can be
a good [ __ ] person without a father
figure so why do you inherently need one
because me personally I'm big on family
my family supports each other around so
I'm saying support system I'm talking
about aunties uncles they all get
involved it's not just the fact it's not
just it's not just the father only that
still does my place of Father it doesn't
basically further figure by itself no
the support system is support it's not
like the actual helping you need like
the father is not there but you're being
supported by people around you okay so
it makes it easier for you yeah okay so
but that still doesn't replace having a
father in there he does he does either
so it is it's going to be selfish if
women choose to not not to be able to
have a father and then go still going to
have a child that's inherently selfish
and what Pearl said all the
statistically disadvantage so if we look
at especially if we look at what's
happening now in London yeah I've
crammal or the stabbers and what's going
on look at who's doing it and when you
when you look at all the kids that come
from single parent homes
but I had a good support system so how
about that yeah but what I'm trying to
say to you is yeah when you so so
exceptions don't cancel out the rule so
I'm glad that you've done well but if
you look at statistics of what's going
on not everyone's like you no one's like
me but I'm saying Carl Champions I'm
from South Africa most my myself can
culture background everyone we know each
other to be supportive of each other
together it's not just a child it's not
just to one person it's a whole
Community raising the child it's not
only you it's not the father would you
would you have preferred to have a
father figure I'm okay with myself right
now no but you didn't answer would you
have preferred it I can't have a
preference because I don't know why it
is wrong okay yes or no would you have
preferred it no because I like my life
right now okay okay it's crazy
I just want to quickly say yeah a lot of
people understand the idea of raising a
child you know you need to have like a
trap you need to have loads of people
around you that has no correlation with
having not having a father figure I feel
like there's a difference between
support and having a tribe to raise your
child because it takes more than one
person you need the aunties you need the
friends you need the cousins the
siblings whatever it may be but a father
figure a father period is something that
is irreplaceable when it comes to a
child especially when they're young
I know I understand them
I'm gonna say that say that in the mic I
said what if the final figure is not
it's not good I found the woman you pick
that's why it's only a woman it's good
for himself a good support system like
right so you can choose as a choice no
I'm saying that's yeah yeah she made the
wrong choice why is it wrong so it's
wrong that my mom made a choice and I'm
here okay okay okay don't get in your
feelings man no I'm not no no no
okay is it wrong to make a child with
someone that is clearly going to be a
deadbeat dad yes that's selfish yes wow
so if I if I was talking to some dude
that just got out of
prisoner which is like tight and close
oh no okay okay I just don't believe
most women there's some sort of red flag
that they either I don't most girls
aren't blindsided they usually choose to
say something so that's why I said it's
on you
and I saw him I'm sorry they saw me it's
not on me like you saying it's selfish
you're just one-sided some people feel
different as well bro I'm happy that
you're hearing it we're all happy that
you're hearing it what happened yeah
[Laughter]
God bless the universe appreciate it if
your dad was a waste man then that's not
your fault but that's your mama's fault
end of the day is week we always put
onus on the men but these women pick
these guys and most of the time okay
cool there's a small percentage I
stop interrupting me when you're 100 in
control of who is born you have more
responsibility
more we have more power that comes with
more responsibility you are responsible
for who gives birth so you you have free
abortion up to six months I'm
responsible as well of of having like
sex with a woman so they can give back
as well as soon as you have sex without
contraceptive you're also just as
involved in the pregnancy
that's not true because the only thing
he has control of is a condom and that
could break where you girls can steal it
the NBA had to issue statements saying
these women are stealing companies wait
wait we we're you can get an IUD that's
99.5 effective you can get birth control
if that doesn't work you can get the
Plan B pill if that doesn't work you can
take the abortion pill if that doesn't
work you get an abortion up to three
months there's no excuse I'm not
disagreeing with you they are outliers
but you're talking about our lives
if you wear a condom properly
let's take the condom example okay you
can say you cannot have sex with me
unless you have a condom on yeah that
women are in control of sex we are in
control and who has more power the one
who has 41 for wait who has 41 forms of
birth control are the one who has won
less more power let's also think about
with societal pressures when it comes to
women no don't roll your eyes because
it's a fact now but babe these Quantum
things are true because no no these
people there's a lot of people that
carry this boosting things so it's so
Impressions
it's my Russian action accent of
disgusting but it's just true like to be
honest it's not only about pregnancy
here yeah if you don't wear a condom
this you can be called Lilia chlamydia
you can get gonorrhea you can get
anything you know so that's kind of on
you and if you then like some people
they play Russian roulette with this
pill yet
um they literally skip four days and
they're like four pills in and then they
get pregnant then it's then you know
like if I don't choose to keep the child
you know like that's a thing and also
like I feel like a lot of people get
their emotions caught up in this thing
like let's say yeah you're with your
boyfriend you know it's been cheating
and then you get pregnant as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible